yo whatever happened to your pet monkey
that Molly Maul gave you
by the way Molly Mall just got out yeah
free Molly mom no he's already out he's
home he's not gang yeah yeah he um
I got the monkeys there well one of them
it was actually crazy because I didn't
have my USDA license so when I was on
tour yeah you gotta have a tour because
my monkey got famous in L.A my monkeys
was famous in L.A so everybody was
wearing on the street I swear they got
the monkeys right he had his party you
can go to his parties you can see the
monkeys when they run around drinking
alcohol with you jumping on girls
titties and [__] like you know what I'm
saying it's like they had a bad
reputation woman so well you had more
than one monkey I had two yeah I had two
monkeys I used to like when I raised
them I used to have one on their
shoulder one on their shoulder like in
the studio boom feed them they bottles
like they actually like ripped both of
my ears like my ears like sliced like my
diamond rings came out like they pulled
my diamond rings out damn like really
raise them since like little babies like
diapers like change shitty diapers like
everything like then what I'm doing with
my first kids like but yeah right now
I'm working on getting a USDA license
you know where are they at though did
you have to give them away one of them
they had kicked like my door in my
Mansion Dory when I was on tour and they
took like they ran in my house and took
my monkey like the the animal control
people I guess they were it's like they
kidnapped your kid literally that [__]
was really illegal like and I really
need somebody to uh help me and give me
some assistance with that if you watch
this interview and you know how to like
get a monkey back yeah get the monkey
back because it was illegal some illegal
[__] going on and they took my monkey
all right where's the other monkey the
other monkey is with my family members
in a very safe location
allegedly dude money back yo had a pet
tiger in his backyard let's fly [__]
it's exotic [__] like we Kings we
supposed to live like kings yo yeah
wow two monkeys one's gone one is in a
very undisclosed safe location
allegedly did your did your monkey ever
jerk off
um it got to the age before I lost it
where it started like discovering what
it's like private parts were so like and
it would like sometimes like grab the
[__] it didn't jerk up it is like my
grandma would like grab her [__] and be
like looking at it and just like oh it's
a girl so like when I was uh it was like
2010 I was at Mall's house and he had
his monkey bubs and his monkey had you
probably met bubs this is like he had a
wild monkey
so he had a portable DVD player in his
cage
and on the portable DVD player he was
watching a Curious George cartoon and he
was stroking his dick while watching a
cartoon monkey I swear to God it was the
first time I ever brought two chains
over to Molly Maul's house this is like
2010 and we were tripping out because we
were watching a monkey jerk off while
watching a cartoon monkey that monkey
was Advanced bro that's the next level
that John better turn to a human you
know how the monkeys evolve to humans
that one is close to evolving into a
human because
that's like a normal thing you want to
do is beat your meat my dog don't beat
it to me bro dogs be licking their meat
they be licking their meat yeah because
they don't got hands so they gotta lick
their meat that's what make the next
level turn on the movie
balls balls hey yo hey nah so my I have
a friendship he'd be sucking himself off
for sure pause yeah I mean you know
I guess if you could do it none of us
could do it we can't say hey yo it's not
gay hey it ain't gay
no it's not no no I'll be having a
threesome with my hands